smoke rises from a residential compound
in shimpong Tang in central Myanmar the
fires have been burning for more than a
week elsewhere in the village the child
remains of vehicles and a human skeleton
burned so badly only the Torso remains
villagers allege soldiers arrived on the
afternoon of the 11th of August
searching for Rebel Fighters they stayed
in this Buddhist Monastery for three
days killing and burning anything that
moved this man whose identity we've
obscured survived but many didn't
on that day so many people were injured
or killed shot on the spot many other
people died when they fired artillery
and they killed all the cattle horses
and dogs
in the fields outside the carcasses of
livestock decompose in the Sun for the
community everything is gone
the village of tantlang in Western Chen
state was the site of fierce resistance
in September the Junta responded by
shelling it then burning down more than
150 homes survivors fled across the
border into India
the Human Rights group Myanmar witness
has been documenting these incidents
more than 200 in less than a year it
says across the North and the West
claims don't stand unproof the military
was responsible we need hard evidence
and we're able to identify that a number
of times in significant circumstances
such as the presence of Myanmar military
convoys at the same time in the same
location as when Villages were being
burnt to the ground now that's for us
significantly strong evidence despite
these well-documented atrocities
diplomatic efforts to engage the Junta
persist a recent visit by the UN special
Envoy went ahead just a day after aung
San tsuchi was sentenced to an
additional six years in jail and those
interventions have failed to stop
attacks like this
children hiding from aerial bombardment
an army at war with its own people
Tony Chang Al Jazeera